9 octobre 2012
evit ar 10 du matin jeux coin des rues
clark est sauvé à montréal je suis assis
par terre sur le trottoir en bas de mon
bureau j'ai la tête sur les genoux
j'ai les yeux fermés
j'ai mal au coeur j'ai mal au ventre
chantraine pleurer ça fait dix ans que
j'essaie de bâtir ma compagnie
dix ans que j'essaie de trouver ma voie
trouver celle de mon entreprise ça fait
dix ans que je trouve ça vraiment
difficile j'ai l'impression d'avoir le
poids du monde entier sur mes épaules
j'ai l'impression que tout ce que j'ai
fait dans les dernières années et tout
en train de s'écrouler
je me sens comme devant un barrage avec
des trous pilot commence à passer et
j'ai mes doigts dans les trous pour
bloquer l'eau puis là je suis à court de
doigts j'ai l'impression que le barrage
va exploser je vois tout en noir je me
sens proche
je me sens faible je me sent victime je
me sens loser il pourtant c'est un
entrepreneur et un dirigeant est un
leader jusqu'aux est fort s'ils se pose
est facile pour moi comment des employés
ou des clients mont blanc me suivent
si j'ai la si faible peut-être que dans
le fond est entrepreneur c'est parfait
pour moi
peut-être que je passais fin le 9
octobre 2012 ça a été la pire journée de
ma vie c'est le jour où j'ai vraiment
atteint le fond du baril chose que mon
épouse la super héroïne était là avec
moi sur le trottoir et m'a serrée dans
ses bras qui me disent voter dès et
c'est exactement ce qu'elle fait je sais
pas comment elle a réussi mais la
réussite des nicheurs rendez vous chez
le médecin le jour même m'accompagner
dans la voiture est mort à entrer dans
la voiture par me dis je m'occupe du
bureau occupe toi de rien tout va bien
aller
alors j'allais voir le docteur je me
suis assis dans son bureau je lui ai
expliqué mon histoire je lui ai expliqué
ma vie je vais expliquer qu est ce que
je trouve excellent comme avait été la
dernière année
son diagnostic ça a été que je faisais
des crises d'angoissé du un trouble de
l'adaptation savais que j'allais avoir
une psychologue encore plus de me sentir
moins que rien au froid que j'allais
raconter mon histoire à une étrangère
sur son sofa mais j'avais absolument
rien à perdre déjà dans le fond de toute
façon alors je suis allé je me suis
assis dans son bureau
encore une fois je vais raconter mon
histoire je racontais ma vie qu'est ce
que je trouvais difficile qu'est ce qui
était dit si dans les derniers mois qui
j'étais et elle a fait la première
rencontre est maudit donc marc adresse
j'ai bien compris tout beaucoup
d'empathie pitt est hyper sensible ça
commence à vraiment mal parce qu'à la
vérité y compris l'empathie j'ai pas le
temps pour ça je me disais ça voulait
j'ai des gens qui dépend de moi
l'hypersensibilité ce pour les faibles
c'est pas pour les leaders qui sont sur
deux l'hypersensibilité pile en pâtisse
pas des traits de caractère que
j'associais des grands leaders qui ont
réussi dans la vie mais son message
était rentré dans ma tête et son message
a commencé à faire du chemin dans la
paix ça va être tellement fait mal que
je m'étais juré plus jamais revivre ça
alors j'ai commencé un grand travail
d'introspection un grand travail pour me
découvrir moi même j'ai lu beaucoup de
livres
j'assistais en pleine conférence j'ai
assisté à plein de séminaires j'ai parlé
avec les gens et j'ai découvert que moi
dans la ville je veux être comme ces
gens vous savez ces gens qui vont dans
les 5 à 7 qui sont flamboyants qui
réussissent à nouer des liens avec
chaque personne super facilement qu'ils
sont extraverti pour qui toute la face
il moi c'est à eux que je voulais
ressembler et j'étais pas comme ça skis
c'est ce qui cause est mon plus grand
désespoir ma plus grande détresse
je me rends compte que je serai jamais
comme ça
après un certain deuil avec moi même la
personne que je suis vraiment a commencé
à émerger tout doucement j'ai commencé à
réaliser qu effectivement j'ai beaucoup
d'empathie et je suis hyper sensible ça
ça a été le début de la renaissance plus
que d accepter j'ai décidé d utiliser
comme des super pouvoirs
à partir de maintenant j'allais utiliser
de l'empathie l'hypersensibilité pour va
connaître les gens m'ont ça m'avait pris
33 ans avant de me découvrir moi même ça
m'a pris trente trois ans avant de
découvrir qui je suis vraiment quelles
sont mes forces
quelles sont mes vrais talents jallet
désormais utiliser la reconnaissance
pour aider les autres à découvrir qu'ils
sont vraiment piètre découvrir leurs
forces
parce que dans le fond la reconnaissance
c'est quoi c'est voir en l'autre quelque
chose qui fait bien lui dire ça le fait
sentir bien ça lui permet de se
découvrir et de renforcer ce talent le
kilo alors j'allais utiliser la
reconnaissance à ce moment là mon
entreprise ça plaît inbox international
et on faisait des sites web et je lisais
un livre extraordinaire à ce moment là
qu'ils s'appellent good to great james
corden son livre absolument génial et
dans le good to great j'aime carlens
part du concept du hérisson le concept
du hérisson c'est une stratégie qu'une
entreprise peut adopter pour avoir
énormément de succès puis cette
stratégie là se trouve à l'intersection
de trois cercles
qu'est ce qui nous passionne dans la vie
qu'est-ce qu'on peut être les meilleurs
au monde a faim et qu'est ce qui génère
les dollars dans mon cas je venais de
découvrir que moi ce qui me passionne le
plus au monde c'est de reconnaître les
gens ils rien qui procure plus de
bonheur que dire à quelqu'un à quel
point il est extraordinaire
ça me procure un immense plaisir et j'ai
un certain talent pour le faire j'ai un
certain talent pour voir ça il le dire
aux autres
donc c'est ce que je peux être le
meilleur au monde à faire et ce qui
générait les dollars dans mon entreprise
à l'époque c'est important qu'on avait
fait pour nos clients un portail de quoi
vous pensez
un portail de reconnaissance des
employés
quand j'ai compris son et lumière est
arrivé dans ma tête
tous les morceaux du baso se sont mis
ensemble j'ai enfin compris ma raison
d'être
j'ai enfin compris la mission dont
l'entreprise j'y vois un chemin s'ouvrir
devant moi je savais maintenant
exactement où je m'en allais alors j'ai
décidé de réunir les sept les six
employés on était sept à l'époque donc
j'ai réuni tout le monde dans la salle
de conférence et j'aurais expliqué je
leur ai dit qu'à partir de maintenant on
va arrêter par tout ce qu'on fait on va
faire une seule et unique chose on va se
concentrer et on va faire uniquement la
reconnaissance des employés
vous savez ce qui est fantastique quand
on sait exactement où on s'en va c'est
que le cerveau parfois nous y amène sans
qu'on s'en rende compte
je donne un exemple ça fait déjà un
petit moment que j'essayais de trouver
un moment dans l'entreprise tous les
jours où on pouvait où tout le monde
pourrait partager sur sur quoi ils
travaillent aujourd'hui pour savoir sur
quoi tout le monde travaille alors
j'avais commencé à instaurer un stand au
cnit et se savent pas c'est quoi c'est
un autre midi c'est exactement ce que
l'on veut dire c'est une réunion de boue
pourquoi debout parce qu'après dix
quinze minutes les gens sont tannés donc
ça se tire jamais longtemps
c'est excellent alors je vais commencer
ce soir est un ovni dans ce stand up là
tout le monde à tour de rôle choisissait
parmi l'ensemble des priorités qu'ils
avaient aujourd'hui la chose qui devra
complet ça me semble un concept vraiment
cool et ça a été un lamentable échec
les gens étaient pas là les gens
n'étaient pas là il y avait une longue
liste d' excuses
pourquoi être là on appelle avec un
client un appel conférence rapporte
arrivait toujours une excellente raison
j'ai 6 à 9 heures à 9h15 à 10h à 12h15
ça marchait pas j'ai vraiment sur le
board abandonné et à ce moment là je
lisais un autre livre l'avantagent du
bonheur de schalke un excellent livre et
dans l' avantage du bonheur l'auteur
prétend qu'on pourrait influencer notre
pensée à focus et plus sur le positif
que sur le négatif
on pourrait entraîner notre pensée à
voir les bénéfices les avantages plus
que les obstacles les embûches les
inconvénients
une des façons d'y arriver c'est par la
reconnaissance sépare en voyant autour
de nous ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
pourquoi on peut être
aucune question d'entraîner notre
cerveau j'ai trouvé ça génial justice va
incorporer fois dans le stand alors au
stand up suivant il manque encore des
gens mais ceux qui étaient là je leur ai
dit avant de me donner votre priorité de
la journée vous allez me dire une chose
pour laquelle vous êtes reconnaissants
une chose qui s'est bien passé dans le
dernier 24 heures ils ont trouvé ça un
peu bizarre au début un peu fleur bleue
mais ont joué le jeu n'ont pas le choix
mais assez rapidement il ya deux choses
qui sont arrivées
la première les gens commencent à être
là alors la longue liste des excuses a
complètement disparu et la deuxième
chose c'est là je l'avais vraiment pas
vu venir les gens commençaient à se
reconnaître entre eux
les gens ont commencé à offrir leur
reconnaissance à un collègue
aujourd'hui ma reconnaissance et paola
qui m'a aidé à monter cette conférence
tedx aujourd'hui merci paula j'aurais pu
le faire sans toi aujourd'hui ma
reconnaissance va jonathan qui réussit à
tous les jours à trouver des solutions
tous les obstacles qu'ils rencontrent
encore fait soya remercie jonathan
aujourd'hui dans la compense par pierre
qui a réussi à monter une équipe de
développeurs extraordinaires qui ont des
guides raison incroyable à chaque
semaine merci car imaginez un
environnement de travail où vous vous
rendez à tous les jours vous avez
l'opportunité de vous faire re connaître
pour ce que vous faites de mu ça m'a
pris un peu de temps avant de réaliser
tout ce qui s'était passé
puis avec un peu de recul je réalise que
parce que j'ai commencé un travail
d'introspection sur moi même parce que
j'ai lu beaucoup de livres parce que
j'ai découvert qui j'étais vraiment j'ai
découvert mes forces et que j'ai décidé
de focus et sur mes forces
ça m'a permis de découvrir ma mission ma
raison d'être la mission de mon
entreprise il ça m'a permis de savoir
exactement où je m'en allais quelques
mois plus tard on a fini la
réorientation de la compagnie une boxe
et devenu kerlann on les mettra en 24
employés
on est reconnus comme des leaders en
reconnaissance des employés de plus de
20000 personnes à travers le monde
utilisent nos solutions
on parle de nous dans les journaux dans
les médias on a gagné il n'y a pas très
longtemps le prix jeune entreprise de
l'année
la bns va bien la compagnie va bien tout
va bien mais moi je vais bien ma famille
va bien
mes amis vont bien tous les aspects de
ma vie vont bien j'ai enfin atteint ce
que je considère être le bonheur entre
le moment où je pleurais sur le bord du
trottoir il moment où j'ai commencé à
être heureux il s'est passé une
rencontre enfin c'est passé plusieurs
rencontres
il s'est passé une rencontre avec moi
même il s'est passé deux rencontres avec
mes aspirations personnelles
il s'est passé une rencontre entre mes
aspirations personnelles et la mission
de mon entreprise
s'il ya une chose que j'aimerais que
vous retenir aujourd'hui c'est très
simple arrêtez de vouloir être quelqu'un
vous n'êtes pas arrêté de chercher où
ces pôles bon endroit
tous et chacun d'entre nous on a quelque
chose qu'on fait d'extraordinaire tous
et chacun d'entre nous on a un talent on
a un pouvoir trouver le et focus et là
dessus il absolument rien de nouveau
dans ce que je vous parle aujourd'hui on
parle de ça depuis toujours ce kratzer
connais toi toi même
nietzsche disait deviens ce que tu es
pourtant il ya peu de gens qui
réussissent à se découvrir vraiment moi
je suis heureux aujourd'hui j'ai réussi
à être heureux aujourd'hui je peux le
perdre demain où je peux le perdre dans
dix ans mais c'est pas grave je sais que
je vais le retrouver
parce que maintenant je sais qui je suis
et vous qui êtes vous merci